hey guys today is the 20th of April my
name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games but news physical stuff
that happened a truckload of mass effect
for details have leaked as they're about
as intriguing as they are unverified the
info popped up on reddit a couple of
days ago having been allegedly taken
from an online survey shown by EA to a
fan of the series while this sounds a
little sketchy it's worth noting that EA
have done this numerous times before and
the similar survey leak occurred with
dragon age inquisition wherein all the
info turned out to be true as for the
mass effect 4 info players will adopt
the role of a pathfinder Explorer
searching for a new home for humanity
there will still be the option to elect
to teammates to bring with you on
missions and you'll be able to build
settlements and transition between
flying landing on planets driving the
Miko and venturing out on foot without
being interrupted by loading screens
that's almost a little sad given the
game's iconic elevator loading screens
but all that info is barely the tip of
the iceberg you can find a full summary
of all the alleged story gameplay and
multiplayer details on gamespot get
things up develop a remedy are still
doing their best to get a sequel to Alan
Wake out the door this time with
publishers outside of Microsoft remedy
are currently diverting their time to
Xbox one title quantum break due out
next year but the dev have said that
when that's done they hope to get back
to their well-loved series remedy
creative director sandlake also known as
the face of Max Payne has said that they
are discussing the possibility of an
Alan Wake sequel with quote multiple
partners although he clarifies that
nothing is set in stone and they may
also make a new quantum break game once
they're done on the first one and Alan
Wake to concept video from 2010 was
given to polygons which alludes to a
game mechanic that lets players quote
rewrite reality xbox boss Phil Spencer
has suggested a remaster of the original
Alan Wake
is a possibility but stopped short of
suggesting a sequel might crop up to
finally we have a whole new mess of
details on star wars battlefront and the
news that developer dice want the game
running at 60 frames per second because
of course they do the news was revealed
during a recent twitter Q&A with design
director Nicholas for grace since its
dice a developer behind the battlefield
series you better believe they're doing
their best to cram in some revolution
and they have indeed confirmed that
destruction will play a part for grace
confirmed that map sizes will vary
depending on the mode playable
characters will include Darth Vader and
throop effects and while there weren't
these space battles there will be X on
that the poor planets available at
launch will be indoor hot Tatooine and
Sullust and there will be more than
eight maps at launch with at least two
planet let me know down in the comments
if you're more excited but Alan week to
Mass Effect 4 all star wars battlefront
and why you can add the game spot we've
got use on a brand new halo 5 trailer
and xboxes III plans that's everything I
wanted to tell you about today do let me
know what you cared about and are catchy
same time tomorrow